[Applause]
We are living in a historical moment marked by
a difficult style we know
the world is shaken by the crisis caused
by the pandemic of the expert name which
highlights even more
another global challenge the socio-environmental crisis
this puts us all in front of the
need for a choice the choice between
what matters and what doesn't matter
the choice between continuing to ignore
the sufferings of the poorest and
mistreating our common home
the earth or committing ourselves at every level
to transform our way of
acting  science tells us every day with more
precision that it is necessary to act
urgently and I am not exaggerating this is what
science says if we want to have a hope
of avoiding climate change,
among which it is catastrophic and for this to
act knowledge this is a scientific fact.
conscience
tells us that we cannot be
indifferent to the suffering
of the poorest and to growing
economic inequalities  and
social injustices and the economy itself
cannot be limited to production and
distribution must
necessarily consider its impact
on the environment and the dignity of the person
we could say that the economy must
be
creative in its methods in the way of acting
creativity limit yourself to  undertake
a journey together a journey of
transformation and action made not
so much of words but above all of
concrete and urgent actions
we think of a journey because it requires a
shift a change from this
crisis
none of us must come out the same we
will not be able to come out of a crisis the same never we
leave  equal and it will take time and effort
to get out of it, it will be necessary to go step by
step to help the weak persuade the
doubters to imagine new solutions and
commit to carrying them forward but
the goal is clear to build in the
next decade
a world where we can respond to the
needs of the present generations by
including  all without compromising the
p  possibility of future generations
I would like to invite all people of
Christian faith or not
and all people of good will to
undertake this journey from his
faith or if he does not have faith from his will
in his own good will
each each of us as
individuals and members of  groups families
communities of faith companies associations
institutions and can offer a significant contribution
five years ago I wrote the
encyclical letter laudato sii dedicated to the care
of our common home proposes the
concept of integral ecology to
respond together to the cry of the earth
but also to the cry of the poor
integral ecology is an invitation to an
integral vision of life starting
from the conviction that everything in the world is
connected and that, as the pandemic reminded
us, we are interdependent from each
other and also dependent on our
mother earth
.  need to look for other ways of
understanding progress and measuring it
sen  z to limit ourselves only to the
technological economic dimension and finance of the
gross product but giving a
central emphasis to the social and educational dimensions and type,
I would like to propose today three paths of actions
as written in laudato sii
change and the right orientation for
the journey of ecology and integral
it requires first of all to take an
educational step
so the first proposal is to promote
at every level
an education in the care of the common home by
developing the understanding that
environmental problems are linked to
human needs we must understand
this from the beginning environmental problems
an education based on
scientific data and on an ethical approach are linked to human needs
this important both I am heartened
by the fact that many young people already have
a new ecological and
social sensitivity and some of them fight
generously to protect the environment  and
for justice as a second proposal
we need to put more emphasis  on water
and nutrition access to
safe drinking water is a universal and essential human and social right
because it determines the survival of
people and therefore the conditions
for exercising every other right and
responsibility to ensure
adequate nutrition  for all
through methods of non-destructive agriculture it
should then become the
fundamental purpose of the entire cycle of
production and distribution of food the
third proposal is that of the
energy transition a
progressive but without delay replacement of
fossil fuels with
clean energy sources
we have a few years the scientists
calculate to proceed
approximately less than 30
we have a few years less than 30
to drastically reduce
greenhouse gas emissions into the atmosphere
this transition must not only be
rapid and capable of satisfying
present and future energy needs but also
must be attentive to  impacts on the
poor on  local populations and on those who
work in the energy production sectors,
a way to encourage this change
and to lead companies towards
the urgent need to
commit themselves to the integral care of
the common home by excluding from
investments
the companies that do not meet the
parameters of the  integral ecology and by
rewarding those who
concretely work in this
transition phase to place
parameters such as
sustainability, social justice and the
promotion of the common good at the center of their activity,
many Catholic organizations and
other faiths have already taken on the
responsibility of working in this
direction in fact the land must be worked and
cared for, cultivated and protected
we cannot continue to squeeze like
an orange and we can say that this
care of the land is a human right
these three proposals are intense as
part of a great whole the actions that
we must carry out in
integrated way to arrive at a solution
lasting problems
the current economic system is
unsustainable
we are faced with the moral imperative and the
practical urgency to rethink many
things how we produce how we consume
thinking about our culture of waste
the short-term vision
exploitation of the
poor indifference towards ourselves  them
the increase of inequalities and the
dependence on energy sources on
our challenges but we must think
the integral ecology suggests a
new concession of the relationship between
us with nature this brings a new
economy in which the production of
wealth is directed to the
integral well-being of the  'being human and to the
improvement not to the destruction of
our common home also means a
renewed politics conceived as one
of the highest forms of charity
yes interpersonal love but
also love and politics envelops all
peoples involves nature
therefore I invite all and  all to
undertake this journey I recommend
proposed in laudato  yes and also in the
new encyclical brothers all as
the term amnesty suggests
we must act urgently each of
us can play a precious role if
we all set out
today not tomorrow
today
because the future is built today and is
built not alone but is in  community
and in harmony thanks
[Music]